adiós a uno de los rostros más vistos de
la Casa Blanca en los últimos años
Anthony faushi jefe del instituto de
alergias y enfermedades infecciosas y
principal asesor médico de la Casa
Blanca confirmó su retiro su voz se
escuchó por última vez en rueda de
prensa Este martes nuevamente con el
parte y las recomendaciones para
enfrentar el 19
dejaré que otras personas juzguen el
valor o no de mis logros pero lo que me
gustaría Es que la gente Recuerde lo que
hice todos los días durante estos años
di todo lo que tengo y nunca dejé nada
en el campo
el que también fue asesor del gobierno
Trump representó la respuesta de Estados
Unidos ante la pandemia
hemos visto de manera tan dramática en
la televisión a personas que se
congregan en multitudes en bares sin
máscaras o lugares llenos de personas
sin máscaras
Estoy seguro que eso ha conducido al
rebrote que hemos visto
amado Y odiado tuvo varios momentos de
desencuentro con su jefe anterior que en
varias ocasiones se negó a usar
mascarilla
Simplemente no quiero usar una es una
recomendación ellos lo recomiendan me
siento bien Simplemente no quiero estar
No sé de alguna manera sentado en la
oficina oval detrás del escritorio
resolute el gran escritorio resolute y
usar cubrebocas para saludar presidentes
primeros ministros dictadores Reyes y
reinas
en diciembre tras 54 años de trabajo
ininterrumpidos los republicanos han
prometido investigarlo el funcionario de
81 años dijo que cooperará en caso de
que esto pase